[Music]
we start tonight with another stinging
setback for the special council robert
muller president Trump's lawyer Rudy
Giuliani is saying tonight Robert Muller
will not seek a presidential indictment
now it's obvious why Muller won't even
try because as we've been telling you he
never had a legal leg to stand on
now DOJ guidelines clearly state that a
sitting president can not be indicted
not to mention Muller doesn't have a
reason to even do so in the first place
Muller has zero evidence of collusion
has only been focused on the so-called
thought crimes of the president and it's
not a crime to have thoughts Rudy
Giuliani also reacting to tomorrow being
the one year anniversary of Muller's
corrupt investigation here as part of
his interview will air tonight with
Laura Ingraham take a look at this
what is your optimal timeline for this
to wrap up they should do it today I
mean as soon as possible I think that
they have the facts from which they can
write their report if you're gonna write
a fair report fine write it if you're
gonna write an unfair report write it
and we will combat it we're ready to rip
it apart the former New York City Mayor
he's right about this he also told her
on Laura Ingraham about the damage that
this investigation is doing to this
country and here's what he said when you
look at all the main flash points the
Trump Tower meeting the stormy Daniels
payment the radon mana for at the radon
Cohen is there any one part of that that
concerns you more than other parts of
that yeah their inability to reach a
conclusion that is obvious and their
unwillingness to recognize the damage
this does to our country all over the
world this was engineered by Comey
we'll get out much more on this in just
a minute with Jodha Jennifer our own
Greg Jarrod and Laura's full interview
with Rudy Giuliani airs tonight right
after this program but first on the
foreign policy front tonight President
Trump he's not blinking in the standoff
with Kim jong-un and North Korea now
remember Kim jong-un is now trying to
act tough his egos been bruised he's
threatening to withdraw from the summit
and Singapore North Korea is also saying
that D denuclearization will not be on
the table
yeah well president Trump responded by
stating directly that his peace
through strength policies continues take
a look we haven't seen anything we
haven't heard anything we will see what
happens whatever
well obviously the liberal media and a
frenzy over this development because
think about it for them to succeed it
for the president to fail for the
Democrats that succeeded for the country
to fail but the president is standing
firm on denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula and national security adviser
john bolton is also saying this is just
part of the game that North Korea always
plays except unlike Clinton we're not
trying to bribe the guy the question is
whether this really is a sign that that
they're not taking our objective of
denuclearization seriously you know Kim
jong-un told South Korean president moon
jae-in at their April 2:27 inter-korean
summit that he agreed to
denuclearization and so if they're
walking back from it we'll find out I
think Sarah Sanders said this morning
pretty much what the president's
thinking is is if they're ready to meet
we're ready to meet if they're not ready
to meet then then they would that we
won't meet and we have the three
hostages back he's not firing missiles
he crossed the DMZ okay so far a win now
what's happening here is the policy of
trust but verify
president Trump he's not giving up
anything with North Korea which is why
he keeps saying well we'll see what
happens now Kim jong-un well he's the
one that has made every concession he
gave up the hostages we didn't have to
appease him with a plane load of cash in
other currencies or 150 billion dollars
like Obama did with Iran so the ball is
in Kim jong-un's Court he wants to talk
he wants a deal he wants a better life
for his people president Trump's ready
to listen North Korea will not be
allowed to threaten the world and build
nuclear weapons that's a fact
and the president he's made it crystal
clear all right we're also getting
clarity on another major story tonight
remember how for the past year the
left-wing media the Democrats promising
that Trump Tower meeting was somehow the
big smoking gun of Russia collusion okay
tonight in spite of media reports we now
have the evidence it was a total
thud now the Senate Judiciary Committee
they released thousands of pages of the
testimony several key players at the
meeting the main takeaway is this they
all thought it was a waste of their time
they were talking about adoption the
McGinn ski act no dirt on Hillary
Clinton came through and by the way if
it did it wouldn't be illegal and will
explain that tonight now from all
accounts this meeting quickly went off
the rails eventually focused in on
topics like Russian adoption and Russian
adoption it's a nothing burger and the
media they've been hyping this as a
cruise missile that was gonna take down
the Trump administration Donald Trump
jr. he testified he was skeptical going
into the meeting and that his suspicions
were quickly justified and Donald Trump
jr. also said that his father President
Trump had nothing at all to do with it
in any way shape matter or form and
despite all of this wild and false
speculation it's nothing the Trump Tower
meeting isn't the only breaking news
story that it actually is embarrassing
to the destroy Trump media New York
Times so this is an amazing story
they hate President Trump they're now
basically tonight confirming everything
we have been telling you regarding the
biggest abuse scandal in the history of
the country now it's not a Maher culpa
from the liberal New York Times frankly
was inadvertent which is probably why
the so-called paper of record they're
kind of playing clean up now
this was their original headline tonight
it's pretty amazing a secret mission a
codename and anxiety inside the early
days of the FBI's trump investigation
well they changed the headline codename
crossfire hurricane the secret origins
of the Trump administration great to
know somebody in the FBI likes the
Rolling Stones okay why would they
change it let me explain what happened
in this article it's a long article The
Times explains how the FBI opened a
top-secret completely unconventional
operation into the Trump campaign by the
way only days after they rigged the
investigation into Hillary and the same
exact players now the details were
closely guarded by FBI officials this
all happened days just days after the
same people put the
fixing with the exoneration before
investigation of Hillary Clinton rigging
it knowing she committed felonies and
obstruction of justice in other words
everything we've been exposing so to
break it down this way in the summer of
2016 the FBI sends agents to London they
interview an Australian diplomat
Alexander Downer The Times describes
this interview is quote diplomatic
protocol highly unusual
now remember down is the guy that got
drunk one night with some guy and I knew
I thought I knew everybody in the Trump
campaign joyed Papadopoulos never heard
of him
the Trump adviser nobody heard of and
during that night out are they drinking
they apparently gossiped like I guess
mean girls about so called dirt on
Hillary Clinton towner then alerted the
Australian intelligence agency who then
told their US counterparts
1 2 3 4 way here say now this is massive
The Times is confirming that the FBI is
four weig hearsay to launch an
investigation just like we've been
telling you on the program by the way
their timeline doesn't match up and
hearsay is never admissible never mind
four-way hearsay in a court of law so
what the New York Times is proving is
we've been right the entire time and in
the process of trying to cover-up for
their deep state friends and making
excuses they're actually exposing them
at times in the rest of the media have
been trying to get ahead of what is a
massive scandal and protect the likes of
Comey
and the k-band struck and Lynch and and
Paige and everyone else but they can't
because the facts the evidence the truth
is finally coming out and we have been
promising you this and so far what we've
been uncovering is only the beginning
this is going to get a lot worse for all
of these steep deep state actors before
it ever gets better take a look at the
side of your screen
James Comey Andrew McCabe Loretta Lynch
Peter struck Lisa Paige all at the
center of this massive scandal Comey is
a liar and a leaker and probably broke
the law multiple ways mccabe lied under
oath multiple times he could be facing
criminal charges Loretta Lynch oh she
tried to compromise the Clinton email
investigation and get called me to say
it's not an investigation it's only a
matter then you have the FBI anti-trump
lovebirds struck in Page they routinely
abused the president verbally attacking
him in their text messages and structs
fingerprints are all over everything
now we'll have more on that in just a
second now we have another big story for
us to tell you about the DOJ s attempt
to slow walk Stonewall obstruct Congress
from ever seeing over 1.2 million
documents about the Clinton email server
investigation and the Russia witch-hunt
which should be coming to an end
congressman mark meadows Jim Jordan Ron
de Santos they're now asking the
president to use his executive authority
instruct the Attorney General jeff
Sessions who should be doing it on his
own to immediately turn over all
documents that Congress has subpoenaed
and as a constitutional right Cole
branches of government and a right to
oversight and separation of powers it is
insane it is unfair to you the American
people that it has come to this as
Congress has the constitutional
authority as part of their checks and
balances rod Rosenstein he has been
concealing information and then
needlessly weird acting key parts of
these things in the name of national
security that gets proven later not to
have anything to do with national
security Rosen Stein claims that but
it's not true we've seen this lie play
out it's about protecting all of his
friends I mean while he is conflicted
from the very beginning of all this and
by the way was a no-show for a
closed-door hearing with the Senate
Intelligence Committee today I wonder
why now several obama administration
officials they were quoted but Comey
dodged the entire thing that's telling
think about this
congressman Jordan and DeSantis will
join us in a few minutes all right one
more thing tonight
a major follow up on the former Obama
official who at one point voted for the
Communists for president this is how
this man ever became the CIA directors
breathtaking to meet John Brennan Paul
Sperry reporting the Brennan who has
repeatedly threatened president Trump
you know stay tuned mr. president is now
being exposed yet again as a liar this
time by his former colleagues last May
the former CIA director testified under
oath the dossier didn't factor into the
intelligence community
assessment of Russia election mentally
we've got the tape to prove it take a
look
you know if the bureau ever relied on
the steel dossier as any as part of any
court filings applications petitions
pleadings I have no awareness did the
CIA rely on it no one I because we we
did it wasn't part of the corpus of
intelligence information that we had it
was not in any way used as a basis for
the intelligent assessment that was done
it was it was not Mike Rogers and James
clapper are contradicting Brennan and
saying that yes the dossier did play a
role into what American intelligence
agencies concluded just like the núñez
memo and just like the Grassley Graham
memo and on top of all of that Sperrys
reporting the Brennan hand-picked Trump
Peter Peter struck to help work on this
report the same guy who put the fix in
for Hillary and the same guy who trashed
President Trump and text message after
text message and then a few days after
exonerating and rigging the Hillary
investigation launches an investigation
into Donald Trump this deep state is one
huge giant incestuous corrupt swamp and
the more we learn that Peter struck is
involved his dirty fingerprints are over
everything why does this guy even still
have a job